was very quick thank you very much for
settling down i know some of you are
coming back from from classes so
thank you for coming on time i'm kim
goff cruz i'm the vice president for
student life and it is my pleasure as we
celebrate the constitution this week to
be able to invite those of you in the
audience and those of you who are
watching the live stream to a very
special conversation with supreme court
justice stephen breyer with our own
margie marshall who is the yale
corporation senior fellow and of course
with yale president peter salovey so
welcome
justice breyer's wisdom as we all know
is about constitution was quite broad
and has had a significant impact on the
court's work
providing timeless principles for
situations which of course the those who
created the constitution did not imagine
at the time and so we were particularly
grateful as he's here with us to welcome
him back not only to yale but to also
thank him particularly for the time that
you're going to spend with students
today and making them a priority during
your visit
now those of you know chief justice
marshall that she brings her own
expertise to this conversation she is
the former chief justice of the
massachusetts supreme judicial court
as also a defender of human rights both
in south africa and the united states
a long-time university leader and of
course most importantly a graduate of
deal law school
so you want to welcome her back and of
course president salovey who needs no
other introduction other than the fact
that he is our esteemed leader and today
he will serve as moderator for the panel
now before we start i'm going to ask all
of you in the audience to please silence
your personal electronic devices we'll
take a moment
for you to do that thank you so much
and with that i'm going to turn over the
panel to chief justice marshall thank
you very much kim and welcome to all of
you it is wonderful to see such a packed
house really wonderful
um
and kim said yesterday was the
anniversary of the constitution
that's the united states constitution
and it's 227 years old
and while on the subject of age
when i graduated from the law school
that's this one just as well
um
40 something years ago well not quite
almost as old as the constitution
there were no classes
on global constitutionalism
there were no classes on human rights
and
it's taken
a great deal to have that become such a
central focus of this law school
part of that of course is because of our
amazing faculty
dean robert post who's younger than i am
a lot
um professor lever siegel
and judith lesnick who i don't see at
the moment oh there you're sitting right
next to
and who's a lot younger than i am
but it's also
it just is wonderful because of what's
happened around the world
and of course um she doesn't want me to
thank her but i just want to mention
that this is
the gluba program for global
constitutionalism and women's rights and
so i'm delighted to say that we are part
of
really a fabulous international movement
so um
i think what most of the students here
want to know justice breyer is how do
you become a supreme court justice
so i'm going to give you some hints
just looking at what he did to become a
justice
first of all you have to be fluent if
you are native born in the united states
in at least one other language other
than latin
so for those of you who don't speak
fluently another language
forget it
fortunately justice breyer is fluent
in french he always told me he was and
last night when i heard him talking in
french i can't really tell how good your
accent is but you were pretty good at
least it sounded to me at least the
person to whom you were talking wasn't
wincing
right
the second is you have to be a great
public servant
you can't start your life wanting to be
a justice of the supreme court at least
i'm hoping you didn't start your life
that way
but justice flyer as you probably know
has worked in all three branches of our
government all three branches are
responsible for the constitution not
just justice and justices
and he has worked obviously in the
judiciary first as a law clerk on the
united states supreme court
as a law professor
which might be an impediment
in the executive branch
and most important in the legislative
branch where he was counsel to the
senate judiciary committee working for
one of massachusetts great senator
senator edward m kennedy
justice blair is a teacher
a great
teacher that is different from being a
scholar and an academic he loves to
teach
and we hope that today
you will think of him as a teacher so
that you can ask him the questions that
you want to ask him
about anything
he will tell you if he can't answer the
question
but we don't protect him and so you can
ask him anything and he can decide
whether or not he wants to answer it
so justice player it is just one day
after the anniversary of the
constitution
what should
this group of students their friends
their colleagues
know
about the united states constitution
what should they think about how should
they look at it
should they bother with it is it
important
what should they know
yes
and the follow-up question is why
you know about the constitution now
you've gotten a whole lot of things in
that first of all you gave me a very
nice introduction which i appreciate i
could return that introduction and i
will tell you between helping people
lead decent fair lives in actual result
and having it come through i hate to say
between the two of us who's done more
but i'll tell you it isn't me
and uh also uh
a great mistake people make about the
supreme court i can only say the first
one oh the other come up but the first
one is they don't understand
that law in the united states
is made in the states
95 96 97 percent don't forget that all
family law
state
education law state
criminal law state
business law state
uh even uh
environment
state
so when i talk to this group which is a
great chance for me because you're just
the group i want to talk to i say the
first thing that i'd like you to have in
mind is you want to make a difference to
other people's lives
don't forget
if you're a lawyer or connected with law
that city council and this by the way
i've given this speech before come to
think of it he just reminded me at yale
they had a group of chinese uh
professors who were visiting and lawyers
chinese lawyers judges so we were
talking i give the same speech i often
give the same speech many times but but
the point is is i said
where is the law made that affects you
here and i had a hesitation what's the
capital hartford hartford okay god at
hartford not washington dc western d.c
they get their names in the paper that's
because the journalists are down there
and they don't like to move and so they
but but here hartford is the place if
not the city council okay so at the end
of the two days
uh one of the uh uh
chinese lawyers says uh the questions
just have one question why do they make
all the unit law in the united states at
harvard
okay anyway
you get the point that was another point
you brought up i didn't let go you
didn't pass me by that snide remark
about the harvard law school where i
taught for many years and was a student
but for 18 years i've come to this
seminar here so i've learned something
but and i'm not going to say a word
about the fact that at harvard people
talk about yale they say it's an acronym
for youth against law and education
you're back to the constitution and this
is the document
and
one of the things we do
one
because we also interpret federal
statutes and we interpret we and we
don't deal with state law
we deal with law in our court made by
congress
federal administrative agencies and this
document the constitution of the united
states
and and that's the document
well there are many things i'd like you
to know about it but i'll say i'll start
with one
what is it about
what does it do
it's good to start there
not too hard
to say it not in one word or two but not
in a million either
it has a system
it has a framework
a framework for a government
what kind of a government a kind of
democracy
what kind of democracy a democracy
that has institutions that give power to
the people to say what kind of state
federal local or other organization they
want their community to be in to what
they want what laws they want it's the
people's job not the judge's job
but
it is the kind of democracy that
protects basic human rights they're
listed mostly in the bill of rights
the structures in the first seven
articles
bill of rights basic human rights
a degree of equality
that's the 14th amendment
a separation of government power
vertically and horizontally vertically
states federal horizontally three
branches so that no single group of
government people can become too
powerful
and that insists upon a rule of law so
you say those five things you say
democracy human rights equality uh
separation of powers and the division of
powers and rule of law you've got the
heart of it that's it that's not too
hard to remember you can even remember
that for a quiz tomorrow
and once you have that uh fill in the
rest with the details
but all nine of us i think will agree
upon that general description
now why are we celebrating this today
not too many people do celebrate it
but why
and she's part of it just as much as we
are
in the supreme court
it is a rule of law
what does that basically mean
it means for 200 years or more
people in the united states originally 4
million today 310 million have with all
kinds of ups and downs learned how to
live together under the rule of law and
come into the courts hers mind others
and their basic differences are often
not always but often resolved under this
document and other statutes not in the
streets with fists guns and knives you
say that's such a simple idea everybody
knows that good
i'm glad you do
and i hope you remember it
because 310 million or 320 million have
been held together
what about the future i don't know
that's yours okay that's in two
sentences uh why i think it's important
which was your question
it was
mr president i
i just don't think that you should take
that description of yale so why don't
you just ask the next question first of
all uh
let me thank you all also for uh joining
us today and let me thank uh justice
breyer for uh being being willing to put
up with something that we love to do
with
people who have a long association with
harvard and that is to sit them in front
of a backdrop that says
yell in multiple colors about 40 times
uh
let me let me ask uh a follow-up to that
question and and that is uh as you took
out that uh constitution from your
pocket is there something distinctly
american about that document
well that's a good question if you go
back
if you go back
you see it reflects the ideals of the
french enlightenment
the scottish enlightenment
but if i were to pick out one thing
which is a little esoteric
but i think important and you probe into
the
thought
of an american you're more likely to
find this it's something that madison
said
he said that this this document
is a charter of
liberty decreed
by
power
let me put it the other way a charter of
power see that's too bad there we are it
was a really good phrase i was about to
say and i just mucked it up completely
by getting it backwards don't do that
wipe that out it is it is a charter of
power
decreed
by liberty
not a charter of liberty
decreed by power now that's wonderful
because nobody knows what it means what
it means is basically this
in europe
there's a king
at that time
but still even when there isn't
power flows from a central authority
now that central authority which has
residual power
may well decree liberty
so that people are very much free
but in the united states
the individual
is free
and gave power to the central government
so if it isn't here they don't have it
and the residual is back in the people
now why do i think that's so important i
think it is uniquely american and i
think it is pretty important
when somebody asks as they often will
ask me
why don't you belong to more
international courts
i tell them that
and i say
look at the judges in the united states
who appointed you and it was welled
it was republican governor governor
elected
who appointed me oh that's another thing
you got into appointments that's a
different story the main characteristic
of a person who's appointed is he's
lucky the the
the the the uh uh
uh but
elected
official president clinton
president carter
elected
you see
there's a line of responsibility back
through an elected authority
to the people
and that matters to people that matters
they may go too far in many of the
states when they elect judges
but that line of legitimacy traced back
to the people does matter and has
mattered for 200 years
and there is a tendency which i don't
really think is it should be
determinative
but there is a tendency to say but who
are those people over there
those judges
they weren't elected
and moreover there's no tracking it back
to me you say it comes from a treaty but
that's pretty far pretty distant
and if
we're going to overcome that
we have to have reasons
we have to explain it we have to be
careful
we have to make certain that they're
willing to accept it
but that is american i think and and i
can understand it
and uh
it's uh not wholly a bad thing
it has its pluses and minuses
so let me just let me just ask you a
couple of questions
one of the things that you know and i
look to this group of young people
you've just heard justice flyer say
it
it's
it's fundamental appointment process
that the federal branch the
massachusetts bench is through an
election an elective process there's
some accountability it's an elected
official
and yet
so often we see
that
power of the president not inform
discussions and debates
about who should be the next president
who should be the next governor why do
you think that is
i mean people care a lot about the
united states supreme court
it's headlines not a big election issue
i don't know i was told that but do you
think you agree no it's not election and
yet you know
technical
uh not in the newspaper every day i'm
glad to say
uh uh the uh uh interest to lawyers
of interest law students
interest to certain interest groups
within parties
right very much so
but broadly i mean i've had a lot of
people who know politics tell me that
election is not going to turn rise or
fall on the supreme court of the united
states
now that may no longer be true i don't
know what do you think i mean you've
seen the same thing in massachusetts i
don't think it does and i to some extent
there's part of me that says i'm
delighted that it does yeah me too
that it really doesn't in any case so
there is an exceptionalism to american
constitutionalism
and yet here we are talking about global
constitutionalism and i think
you know our history is we are cautious
about other courts international courts
um
we have treaties
there's a kind of tension
between
talking to thinking about
engaging in sighting
footnoting well you don't footnote so
that's okay um i mean no
is that a conversation is that looking
for guidance is that looking for
precedence
um
you know if we've got great courts um
all over the world now that have you
know liberty constitutions free speech
they may have a different structure of
government helpful or not helpful to
engage in those conversations very
helpful
because
a lot of reasons
when i use uh you may learn something
that's the main reason
and often you do often i do
uh another reason it depends on what
court because because as we get
we're getting now to do what i think and
probably you think is a pretty important
question people don't care that much
about the judges in elections do they
when they're electing the positive not
really
some do and so forth but not that many
right
um
they're not very familiar with what
judges do
agree agreed
but
and you say that's sort of surprising
because we do some things that are
pretty unpopular
you do i don't oh yeah
you don't
you don't uh the the uh
uh now
and they affect people oh yes
so that's the question that
wha
why
why is it
and i get this all the time and i'm sure
you did too
we do
why do 310 million people do what we say
why do six million people in
massachusetts do what you say
why
i mean oh
we you know have no weapons etc
uh and i get that question the the
president's supreme court of ghana two
years ago she put it so well and she's
really trying to make reforms in ghana
why do they do it
that is a big question
and an important question
and uh they didn't always
how long do you want me to go on with
this answer this is good
let me let me follow up let's break it
into parts
follow up the beginning part of justice
marshall's question which seemed to be
uh asking
how much should uh
american
justices judges rely on refer to
think about the reasoning of
justices from other
other countries i know you've written a
little bit about this and and debated it
with others but and the reason why i ask
is not to get into the sort of debate
but it's because i look at this group of
people who come from all over the world
they know their systems they come here
it's a wonderful law school we are
delighted to have them and we're
training
lawyers and undergraduates and everybody
else to think about they they operate in
assist when i came from south africa
there was no internet
it wasn't possible for me to lead
judgments or decisions
you know of the german constitutional
court except with great difficulty they
weren't translated and so on and so
forth
this is a generation of people who just
who don't think nationally they think i
mean in many cases and so i think they
find it a lot of odd question that they
should be
perceived limitations i mean where's the
role of nation
courts in a sort of global environment
well let's do that i'll give you one
example
give me another
uh this is a political debate right it's
not a legal debate
i am with a congressman good congressman
uh at a meeting as we have sometimes
have a judge of a congressman now have a
couple of law professors
and this subject comes up
of course and he launches into this why
are you referring to decisions of courts
of other countries
so
they're not elected because they're
stupid they're not
and i said i guess that i fall right i
say i guess that's aimed at me
because i have he says yes it is
so i say well let me tell you the reason
that i do is more and more
uh
nations in the world have constitutions
like ours they try to protect democracy
basic rights
more and more have
just judicial systems like ours this is
a means to help enforce those
constitutions and problems become more
and more similar across the world
so if i have a person in a profession
like mine
interpreting a document like mine
in the face of a problem like mine why
don't i read what he says
i'm not bound to follow it i might learn
something
i thought that's a really good answer
isn't it yeah he said okay read it he
says just don't refer to it in your
opinion okay not knowing enough to shut
up
i continue and say yes but you see there
are many courts
that are new in this game
eastern europe
comparatively so all the places they're
trying to establish it
they refer to our decisions
if we refer to theirs when it's relevant
not saying it's binding but just saying
that you know it was helpful or not
helpful
they can go to their
legislators
and say look what we're doing is an
important thing and it's recognized
elsewhere in the world as such and that
helps us
he says
that's fine
write them a letter
okay so i can give a lot of good reasons
why we should do it we might learn
something we might be helpful to others
etc
but where he's coming from
those answers are not going to be
satisfactory
and it isn't just pure isolationism
it is that which you first brought up
it is that which is add to that
suspicion that all the judges think
alike politically and so they're going
to decide the same thing and they'll be
in no but put it in better terms
put it in terms that's fair to his
argument
what he's worried about
and many are
is that our quote
uniquely american or originally american
or american is
copied abroad or american is descended
and we copied it but those things about
that i mentioned those five things in
the constitution
that they'll somehow disappear
that they'll somehow be watered down
that they'll somehow not be as strong as
they were
that our american features
that we admire in this constitution
will become merged into some kind of
general we know not what
that i think is the underlying fear
you've seen that as well so therefore
i'm trying to work on something
which will show
let me tell you why that question
your concern
is is not relevant today
it's not that it's wrong
it's just that it's not relevant
that we live in a world where if you
look at our docket
you will see
that we have cases
constitutional cases treaty
interpretation cases statutory cases
where you cannot decide it properly
unless
you know something about
decisions
legal practices
other practices
the world outside the united states
i'm going to show that to you and i'm
going to show you what they're about
and i'm going to show you what kind of
questions they raise
and when you see the nature of those
questions
i hope
that you will come to the conclusion
that the only way
to preserve
are american if you like values which
are now widely widely shared
the five that i mentioned
and perhaps others
is to know more
not less
about what goes on abroad
and to refer to it in decisions not
because it's necessarily binding
but because then other people
know
transparently the basis upon which
you're deciding and can criticize praise
or blame as they wish so that the law
advances that's the whole argument
and president salovey you teach not law
has it does it make a difference to you
that you sit at the top of a great
institution i mean have you seen similar
kinds of changes are there things that
you would like
your students to learn from justice
flyer
well that's a that's a great set of
questions i will say one thing that has
changed in just the years that i've been
at yell relevant to this
uh last topic uh you know i'm a
psychologist i taught introductory
psychology for many years in this room
and
in 1986 when i first started teaching
the reference to studies done anywhere
else in the world the reference to
theories that had
grown up anywhere else in the world the
reference to findings from cultures
other than dominant american culture
dominant culture in america
uh were very few and far between there
was almost no interest in fact it was
there was this very bizarre logic that
uh
that that created noise in whatever we
were thinking that was that was that was
adding error
uh that completely switched uh over the
25 years and now to develop to only look
at findings
uh that are uh local to only look at
theories that are homegrown uh would be
considered limit limiting that your
theories don't generalize they're not
externally valid uh uh
there's no generalizability uh
of what you're saying and i just watched
this shift in my field maybe my field
was late to this maybe maybe not
but it was really the same question
people went from deep suspicion
in one direction to deep suspicion uh in
another let me ask a little bit
different question though
in a different direction last night
several of us were lucky enough to have
dinner with justice breyer and the
conversation we were having around our
table
was
whether decisions of the court
could push society in new directions
create change public opinion uh motivate
uh
motivate social movement motivate a
great opinion shift both of these
justices having been involved in cases
that were of great consequence to
our social lives
um or whether uh
uh that's a not the role for uh even to
be thinking about for the court doesn't
really happen the court is reflecting
larger changes in society
that might be evolving anyway and we
were talking a little bit about brown
and we're talking about gay marriage
we're talking about you know what is it
reflection or is it motivation is it the
push or is it is it the reflection
and i guess what i'm asking is uh can
at least
with respect to the judiciary can
can stateways change folkways
oh
the obvious example of that was brown
which is of great interest
for
another reason i want margie to say
look the big question
for everybody here just as much as for
me and for margie and
for the president here
is
go back
why do people follow this i mean brown
told them they couldn't segregate
anymore
why'd they do it
they felt pretty strongly in the south
about segregation they liked it well i
mean some liked it
i mean perhaps
all right you see the point
now
tell them margie knows this i mean
this is it was a south africa that faced
this same question
you know they have a court it's an
excellent court
are people going to do it now we've
talked enough so you see what these the
the it is it
are cases of which there are plenty
too many perhaps but they're important
to people they make a difference in
their lives
that's what you're talking about
uh they're
pretty controversial
not popular
at least in some quarters
and
they could be wrong what about bush v
gore
i wrote a descent so i mean
uh uh okay
so will people follow it
south africa who is the key to that i've
heard you talk about him
so the justice is talking about south
africa post 1994 with a wonderful new
constitution
bill of lights
and
nelson mandela is the president
tutor to president and he's the head of
the african national congress
and
he's trying to get
support across the country there's one
part of south africa which is
not so african national congress
and
there was a decision made by the local
anc
parliament about how to
allocate political power in the cape
area
and there was a challenge
that was inconsistent with the
requirements of the
constitution and they went to court
and the constitutional court said excuse
me you got it wrong
okay
this is nelson mandela this is the court
telling this revered figure you got it
wrong
you got it long
i can't think of the functional
equivalent except bush against goal
you know people felt pretty strongly
that they get as long
right
and nelson mandela the next morning went
out on the steps of parliament and said
this is a victory for all south africans
today our new government shows that it
doesn't matter how powerful you are
you are subject to this
i wish i had the south african
constitution i actually an american
citizen so i carry around the same
constitution it's a little book a little
longer but essentially has the same
principles
and
he was telling his party
he was telling the people of south
africa
we have a new system and he was most
important
making a point about power
that there is a limit
to power
there's a footnote
yeah because i we discussed this once
before in a panel and margie didn't know
that i i didn't know what she uh was
saying there i wasn't there but i was at
the 10th anniversary of the court in
south africa and at that time mr mabecki
was the president and the judges and the
lawyers there were a little uncertain
about how would he have said the same
thing
right
and they were a little uncertain about
how he was going to react in terms of
enforcing a decision of the uh supreme
court the constitutional court that he
didn't like and uh they had a he gave a
talk it was fine uh and then we had a
dinner at the dinner celebrating it's a
beautiful courthouse and uh it was in
the courthouse and started on the site
of the old jail where they put the
apartheid demonstrators and the
anti-apartheid people and so forth and
uh
in this dinner suddenly by surprise sort
of at the end uh lots of tables in the
room in comes
mr mandela
and if you've ever seen him you know
beaming i mean
unbelievable charm and unbelievable i
mean just attraction and he gets up and
he tells that story
you could hear the size of relief in the
room
mr bebecky was right in front of him
who is he talking to
yes mr mcbecky
you see and that's the question
that the president of the court in ghana
is asking
and i like to put it because i wrote
about this i i put it in terms of
hotspurs question i said great
you know uh in henry iv
you have uh owen glenn dower who is a
mystic because he's welsh all welshman
and shakespeare are mystics
and owen glenn dower says i can i can
summon uh demons from the vastly deep in
hotspur your practical englishman says
so can i so can any man but will they
come
when you do call for them
that's the question
and it's a question that hamilton
doesn't write about
and that's her question
and
my answer to that is i can just tell you
about two or three stories briefly and i
tell her about the story of the cherokee
indians
in the 1830s
who owned northern georgia
how do we know that the treaty said that
of course gold was discovered and the
georgians said well why should the
indians have the gold after all they're
just indians we should have it and so
they took it and the georgians being the
indians being a highly civilized group
hired a lawyer
the best lawyer of his day
willard wert
who eventually got the supreme court to
say
of course it belongs to the indians the
cherokees
at which point you probably have heard
or may have heard andrew jackson the
president's famous comment supposedly
john marshall has made his decision now
let him enforce it
and jackson sent troops to georgia but
not to enforce the decision rather to
drive the indians to oklahoma where they
went over the trail of tears because so
many died on the way and they're still
there you see
and that wasn't that long ago was
history and then we go forward in
history
and uh the most important case to me i
told that to a russian
paratrooper
who was sent to our court by the state
department about two decades 15 years
ago because he'd been in charge of
pointing missiles in the united states
and they changed direction
and state said we've got to be nice to
this man
all right so he said show him the
supreme court fine i should
and i said what's your favorite case i
said well brown is an important case in
this century perhaps the most important
but my favorite
cooper versus erin
why because what happened after brown
1954 nothing
1955. nothing no well close to nothing
1956 nothing
57 next to not well
a judge in little rock says go integrate
central high do it september
yeah but governor father said no
and on the day those nine the little
rock nine and this what's terrible is i
went i'm annoyed at this you see i went
to a meeting at harvard don't say it
wasn't yale but it wasn't it was harvard
where four of the little rock nine are
there
only a year ago
and it wasn't much of an audience
they're heroes those nine
they're heroes
and they walked and thuba said i have
the police that judge doesn't
out
and there were mobs in front of the
school and people are we can remember i
remember that
the press was there across the world
and there they were being and there was
a picture of elizabeth eckford who is
reading her book and being turned away
with a girl in the background uh helen
bryant and her face is contorted with
rage at the thought of a black student
going into that white school
and everyone saw that in the world and
what would eisenhower do and he was told
by jimmy burns
governor of north carolina a moderate on
race and former member of the supreme
court he quit during world war ii to
help run the war effort but he said to
eisenhower if you send troops you better
be prepared for a second reconstruction
are you prepared
you'll have to occupy the south
but herbert brownell his wise counselor
said do it you've got to do it and
within a matter of two or three days
eisenhower made up his mind went on
television radio i can't remember then
but he said 101st airborne
a thousand paratroopers
flew from fort bragg into
little rock and everyone in 1957 knew
who the 101st were they were the heroes
of normandy their parachutes had gotten
caught in those steeples where they were
shot they were the heroes of the battle
of the bulge and he knew what he was
doing eisenhower by sending them into
little rock
and they took those black children and
they walked with them into that white
school and that was a great day it was a
great day for the law it was a great day
for uh
the cause of equality and it was a great
day for the united states of america
and i'd say i wish i could end the story
there
but i can't
because a long palm thing pow the little
talk they close the high school
they tried alternatives they went back
up to the supreme court where all nine
said integrate and you have to we order
it but they were nine
and so the governor closed the school
but he couldn't make it stick
too much had gone over too much water
had flowed over that bridge
and we have the freedom riders and we
have martin luther king and we have all
the different events that took place in
the 60s and now with all of that with
the court helping
but not determining
integration gradually came about in the
south
and i said i want her to know that story
and memorize it
because now when we have you said bush v
gore bush vigor was one of the decisions
i'm talking about what
affects people
unpopular unpopular with at least half
the country
maybe a little more than half the
country but
but
still
unpopular and in my opinion wrong but
i've heard harry reid say about that
that the most remarkable thing about it
is never remarked there were no riots in
the streets
there were no
guns fired
and when i talk to a group of students i
i bring that up and i say i know
perfectly well 20 of you are thinking at
least 20
too bad there weren't
a few riots
i said well that's what you're tempted
to think turn on the television set
and see
see
how and what happens
in countries where they don't appear
before the court of law and aren't
prepared to follow decisions that are
unpopular
that may be harmful and could be wrong
well you see you can't have it both ways
and we've gradually over a long period
of time
come to the place where people will
follow it and that to me is a great
treasure but what i'm telling to her is
you want that to happen in your country
don't just talk to the judges
don't just talk to the lawyers
contrary to popular belief
there are 310 million out of a 311
million americans who are not lawyers
they're the ones you have to convince
so find ways of getting to the people in
the villages
because what you have to convince them
of
is
that it is in their interest to follow a
system where they will from time to time
have important decisions affecting their
lives that they don't like at all and
that may even be wrong
huh
by the way
this institution does not respond to
politics
i mean only very generally you're
talking about your institutions yeah i'm
talking about judges you're talking
about massachusetts i'm talking about
the united states elections we say don't
turn on it
and i don't know where they do they
might some places but rarely
you see
now that's a tough assignment
that is a tough tough assignment
but naturally being a judge i think it's
an important one and it being
constitution day you see how what i'll
say to the students is well there we
have it and we think we've got this
problem solved no we don't
we've had it solved in the past to a
degree
from my generation up to a point
but it's up to you
you say
and if i want to go on with my fourth of
july speech
i said i tell the students this i'll say
well you know
i can't tell you how to lead your lives
and i surely can't
i hope
that you'll have a profession
i hope you will find someone to love
i hope that you will participate in your
community's life
and that could be the library board if
you like or it could be politics or it
could be voting and i can't tell you
more than my hopes
but i can tell you one thing i do know
something not a lot but something about
this document and the people who wrote
it will say if you are not going to
participate in public life
this won't work
and so what i think we can do the most i
mean you know i like derek bach actually
bringing in harvard he found a pretty
good quote which he says comes from uh i
think thucydides
or no it's pericles who's giving the
great funeral funeral oration i'm
delighted you know it's an important
thing and i don't know if it's really
true but i think he says this he says
derek's as he said all right he says
look he's talking about the virtue so
they have athens
and he says in athens what do we say
of a man who does not participate in
public life
we do not say
there is a man
who minds his own business
we say there is a man who has no
business here
pretty tough
pretty tough
but i think you want to get into the
minds of the framers
that's what they're assuming
that's what they're assuming
and that's why madison is writing about
ancient greece
and that's why they're looking all over
the world from models of democracy
and that's why eventually they wrote
this constitution where power would flow
from a participating public
uh and that i think is the most
important thing uh that we can talk
about and think about on constitution
day
all right thanks wonderful so i think
the time has come to shift to your
questions and uh i was given a small
stack of cards here but if someone had a
question oh there's more coming in no
okay if someone had a question that
wasn't submitted feel free to hand it to
me here on the side i'm going to take
these in the order in which they came we
haven't pre-screened them
as you will see i suspect
well while you have the constitution out
of your pocket
this question is
what role do you think principles of
morality have in the process of
constitutional interpretation
well
certainly in law
morality has a role in the senses
they asked us this morning
the uh
criminal law for example is based on
principles of morality that doesn't mean
it reflects them perfectly but it does
mean if if you find that a person has
been convicted for what morally you
would consider doing the right thing
there's something askew here
and and uh it tries to uh
make those things congruent it doesn't
always succeed
but that's a goal
and uh certainly you can look at
the forms
of uh government
as
uh embodied in the document the basic
things i mentioned
as as moral points as well as
practical
civil points
and pretty soon when you start trying to
figure out how our human beings live
together in a society successfully
you try to work out systems of law and
we try to work out some that might more
or less work and allow them uh in a
legitimate way without people having
authoritarian power over others to reach
more uh better working communities is
that a principle of morality or a
philosophical principle of law i don't
know
well i think they're connected
you know we were talking a minute ago
about the
framers desire to have uh have citizens
participate in public life
and that wonderful quote from pericles
this question
uh i think picks up on this in an
interesting twist it says what is your
opinion about the growing demand
to televise the supreme court to provide
the general public with access
to the decision-making of judges
no i can i can tell you the issue
and i can tell you why
i don't think it will happen too soon
but it'll happen eventually
because eventually you'll have judges a
point who've just grown up with this and
i can't understand why it shouldn't be
there
but the issue for us who haven't grown
up with it
is the following on the one hand if we
could have in the oral argument
a television camera most of the time i
think 90 what people would see if they
saw this whole oral argument
is that they would see nine people
struggling with pretty difficult
problems
and they'd soon come to the realization
that there are two sides to these issues
even the ones you think are most
one-sided
and you'd listen for a while and i think
they'd learned something and that would
be a plus
so what's the negative
the negative is
oral argument is about three percent of
the whole thing we get most of our stuff
in writing
and oral arguments very brief
and people identify with people
and they'll see a good side and a bad
side
a good lawyer and a bad lawyer a good
client and a bad client
and um
we're writing our opinions for 311
million people who are not in that room
i mean the law as far as we're doing it
you're writing for all the citizens of
massachusetts and maybe beyond
not the two people who are there
and that's the job of an appellate court
and our court and people won't get that
and that's a risk
but i think mostly if you're really
something very very and you get
different views on this
when they start putting it on television
i say
it's not going to affect me
you know we have the press there anyway
if they want to distort things they'll
distort things so what
in canada doesn't cause a problem
but some pretty knowledgeable people in
the press will say
wait till you see the first time
that they take a sound bite
and they put it on the popular program
and they make you say with a scowl the
exact opposite of what any sane person
would have thought you said
and you think it's tough to do that no
it isn't they're experts
and the first time you said death
penalty thing is all right there you are
torquamata
and uh
you see they will affect your opinions
or you'll keep quiet and won't ask any
questions
and we don't know
the answer is we don't know
but all of us are conservative where the
court's concerned
we are trustees
for an institution that by and large
has served the country pretty well
so i'll say we're nervous about it
and probably that's the most favorable
you'll get i mean nervous uncertain not
aware of what's going to happen
and as long as we're uncertain
it's tough
and that it works in lower courts and
but i used to be totally for it when i
was on a court of appeals i said why not
let in the press who cares besides
they'll never come
perfect
and uh
the press is there of course our
opinions are open they explain
everything there isn't really a secret
part it's really the conference where we
discuss thing frankly
so there you have some of the pros and
cons and as long as we're feeling that
there are these pros and cons and
nervous about what it would do to the
institution you're gonna have an uphill
battle getting us to do it
and uh
i think i'm being honest and saying
that's what i think the problem is
i have to say that the supreme judicial
court has its
its oral arguments televised and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter but you
know it's very helpful for people in the
far part of the state who can't get into
the justices it's very helpful because
of the way you can now if you've got a
particular case coming before the court
you don't have to go and watch and sit
there with all the cases you can go back
and you can anticipate not everybody
practices every single day in the united
states supreme court the supreme
judicial court but the best reason that
i ever saw reference to about why it was
good to have cameras in the court was as
a advertising technique for one of the
lawyers who appeared who said if you
don't think i'm very good go look at my
argument in the supreme judicial court
and had it online as part of his
advertising so you can expect to see
that as well just just right yeah well
what we don't know you said no you know
it's the the the pressure that i think
and growing is a tremendous tendency in
to try in the public mind
to politicize our court
so if i said there were three errors i
think the three errors are one people
don't understand that 98 percent of the
laws state
i think error number two is they think
the way we select cases is just take
this case because oh it would be so
interesting or fun
that we have a wide range of choice in
what we hear we don't there are we
normally take a case because the lower
courts have come to different
conclusions on the same question of law
and that's a pretty rigid practice
and it determines most of what we take
and uh the third mistake i think is uh i
see what you really think you think
we're junior league politicians
and and there i say uh uh and i will say
that the the uh uh 50 are unanimous our
bar decisions the five fours are about
20 25 hardly anyone knows that and it's
not always the same five and same four
by any means at which point uh the
students who've asked the question will
say ah yes that's true but those aren't
the really important cases i'll say
you're wrong about what's important
and what isn't important but still what
you mean is those aren't the big sort of
political social issues they're you're
right
and on those
uh well
aren't you a junior varsity politician
um i say no she said well of course
you'd say no
i said well look it's it's it's how can
i put this
these questions are often open
at least the first time
the word liberty in the constitution
doesn't explain itself
the freedom of speech
doesn't tell us exactly what is included
and what isn't
those are open questions often
and if they aren't what are they in our
court for
and in your deciding that and you're
deciding how these values and words
written 200 years ago apply to today's
circumstances
you know george washington didn't know
about the internet
uh so how does the first amendment apply
there i made that brilliant point to
nino scalia when we were talking
together he says you know i knew that
and anyway that's a different story but
but the but of course your background
lowell high school
maybe 1950s
uh maybe my my career
whatever it's been
the fact that i've been in law as i have
by the time you reach a certain age you
have views
how does the constitution relate to the
public what's law about
and people have different ways of
looking at that of course that will
affect you if that's what you mean by
politics rather than is senator kennedy
or senator hatch popular or unpopular
the vote goes democrat where are the
votes that used to be the judiciary
committee who has the votes
that that's kind of politics no
politics in the sense i've talked about
yes
you can't escape your own skin
you can't jump out of your own
background
okay
i accept that
i say we have a court that changes very
very slowly
different presidents appoint different
people
if they think they're going to appoint
somebody who agrees with them all the
time they're pretty wrong
teddy roosevelt appointed all of her
wendell holmes three months later he
ascends in northern securities a big
anti-trust case which roosevelt would
have said was don't dissent
roosevelt says i could carve a judge
with more backbone out of a banana
he was really annoyed
don't expect the judge to agree but on
the level of very general philosophy
but the country the court the way law
interacts with people in this country
values
they're more lucky they're not always
right
but there's a greater tendency so slow
change different presidents over time
people disagree
on some things like that not surprising
nor in a country of 311 million or 12
million people where you there's every
race every religion every point of view
there is no view so crazy that my mother
that there isn't somebody who doesn't
hold that view
everything
imaginable
okay
so it's not so terrible that not
everybody agrees with me all the time
okay
now you see do you get a picture and it
takes it takes time to explain that
picture and see if you get that picture
out of the press sometimes you do when
they're well written you do
and sometimes you don't but i'm trying
to give you a little bit of a in your
own mind compare what i've just said
which i think is pretty accurate
uh with
the picture you get in the popular
television for example often not always
and now you get a sense of the pressure
that we're under
not to further this idea that it's
political
because if it is why have us
why not have congress do it
they're better politicians
good question good question
we haven't actually touched on uh
on judicial philosophy and judging at
all really in a direct way and and this
question
i like because uh it starts off in the
following way
justice breyer you are my favorite
supreme court justice
well she might not know me
that was vaguely political actually
because of the consequentialist
reasoning you deploy in your legal
opinions i struggle
this person says with the disconnect
between law
policy reality on the ground
how do you see the supreme court moving
more in the direction of making
connections between law policy
and on-the-ground reality
what do you think i don't think those
things can be easily separated do you no
no
you know i think um
i want to return to one of the points
that i heard uh earlier expressed which
is
we answer the questions that you ask
right
we don't answer hypothetical questions
if you don't ask us the questions
we can't answer them
you know what is happening on the ground
you know whether or not there might be a
legal answer to it
you know what is best for your clients
we don't
and
the only thing that we have to do
the only thing you have to do as a judge
is decide
or decide not to decide
but we can't send it to committee
so
you know justice blair talked about the
internet i mean am i on facebook no am i
on linkedin no are my grandchildren on
facebook yes
do they read email no
my emails the way i communicate with my
grandchildren is text read your email
right
because if you would like to see me
texting this is how i text
i
and this is how i do email
so guess what read your email
and about two days later i get a reply
if i text them coming to dinner well
first of all i can't do that because i
can only say are you coming to dinner
comma tonight question mark
right
so you no no it's y-o-u any case
so the other kinds of questions for
example
um
think of the questions that are also
technologically
based which is um
husband and wife in those days
decide to go to a sperm bank to freeze
the sperm so that over time
they think they might be able to
have a child
they have a child with the appropriate
technology then husband and wife get
divorced
he goes to a different state
and
she
is in massachusetts as it happens
and she wants she goes to the sperm bank
and says give me one of those sperm
because i would now like to have a child
why because she's reaching the age of 40
and even she recognizes that there's
some limit on the amount of time
and the sperm bank has a contract that's
signed essentially between the
the bank and the two parties on the
other side
so they what do you think they do
they phone the bank phones its lawyer
what are we supposed to do that's where
you come in
right
all of you you have to advise your
client client is really smart and says i
don't have a clue why don't you toss it
to the to the supreme court
massachusetts
thanks i say
now what am i supposed to say
would i like to have legislative
hearings
would i like to know something about
what's going on
answer
i'd love to
i mean we can say
this is a political question we don't
decide those but i mean really i mean
please they've just got a problem here
so
you have to decide
but the lawyers have to help us decide
how do we answer that question
can i take a little bit of your time
you say to your very smart law clerks
who come from good schools
find out what the other courts have been
doing around this country
very smart law clerks come back and say
they haven't had this question rubbish i
said for heaven's sake somebody must
have had this question so i i don't know
tennessee doesn't anybody have this
question no
what do you think the next thing i do is
go and find out what other courts around
the world are doing
as president justice blair
no
uh which which courts chief justice
marshall ah
oh interesting question
which courts
it's like canada i say
why canada
oh i don't know it's like canada it's
written in english and they have got a
constitutional and oh by the way
see if israel's done anything
why well because
they are christian origins who knows i
don't have a clue
vorkler comes back and says israeli
decisions haven't been
translated into english
oh yes they have been i say
well it turns out this late supreme
court had decided
the
precise
issue
precedent
no
helpful
yes
turned out that we were in alignment
with the israeli supreme court but the
court changed its mind afterwards
now we're different how did we decide
if you're going to be the father with
all the responsibilities that we impose
on fathers you have to have the father's
permission
correct decision
who knows
who knows new york times yesterday
front page
issue
state courts are deciding surrogacy
issues completely differently it's a
mess
state courts
where do you think it is going to end up
no why we're not good on family law we
don't have we rarely have a family vlog
you hear that
ask him which way he voted when they had
grandparent visitation
that was a but we're not good at it and
and we shouldn't be uh it's state court
and uh the things that i pay close
attention uh to what chief justice
marshall said because there are a lot of
things in her answer that are
interesting one
matters of great importance and
uncertainty with new technology
affecting families for example and not
the only thing affecting families it's
the states that will decide it it will
not be us so i would take that in
second think of how unusual her case is
i'm a judge
judges decide all kinds of things but
most of them are things like for example
when a railroad abandons a right of way
does that right away
go to the
neighbors who who is it a fee simple or
is it a was it a
some kind of easement and once it
disappears the surrounding property gets
it or can it go back to the federal
government in which case they could turn
it into a bicycle path you know those
are hard enough but they're not going to
be on the front page of the paper but at
least they're law
and and the the uh
question now over here next week
when somebody appeals from a criminal
conviction he's in a habeas court uh in
uh
guts to the court of appeals and uh he
was the government that appealed and he
defended but he wants to defend on a
different ground than the government
ever brought up when can he do it and
when can he not do it those are hard
enough those are legal questions that's
what judges do they sit and decide
questions of law which are hard enough
and these great things like the sperm
bank
or even like privacy with uh
the the stuff that goes on
don't come to us first
now who am i talking to
i'm really the person who captures it's
talkville
he says when he comes to america he
hears a big clamor what's that clamor
it's everybody arguing
they argue good
i mean shouldn't get too violent
but they could argue
argue in law schools argue in
uh journals argue all over the place try
it out try it out in an administrative
process try it out with an
administrative rule if you don't like it
change it try it out in a legislature
try it out as brandeis said in one of
those 50 state experiments try it out
here there that congress passed a law it
didn't work withdraw it etc then
when things settle down and then let the
supreme court decide whether whatever
you came up with exceeds the very broad
boundaries of permission that the
constitution sets
because what this document does is it
does not tell people what to do
what it does is it sets outer limits
on what governments can do
and i usually think of it i used to
listen to a program years ago called
sergeant preston of the yukon
sergeant preston was on the radio and
what he did was he patrolled the
frontier
he was canadian and life on the frontier
in canada is tough in the winter
particularly
it's cold
and is abortion inside the frontier or
outside tough
is uh
you know your case or is it over here
over there tough
but it's the frontier
and what people are forgetting far too
often
is that in deciding whether a solution
reached by others democratically is
beyond the frontier that's rare
and it is not the heart of the matter
the heart of the matter under this
document
is that people in cities towns states
and their communities get together and
they decide through a democratic process
what kind of cities states towns etc
they want
and call us in when you want sergeant
preston but we hope that won't be until
later
until we've learned something had time
to see it simmer down have records to go
to see what worked and see what didn't
work and then maybe
we'll get it right when we tell you
whether the solution reached by others
is beyond the frontier
so i think we've come to the time for
our final uh question
and uh while you still have that
constitution out of your pocket or
almost uh maybe this is a good a good
one to end on
uh what in your view
is the chief deficiency of the u.s
constitution
what's your view mark
they never asked the psychologist i'm
very thankful
actually no no no i have no view
while we're waiting for margie what is
your view
you know what i i was you know
i love the united states constitution i
admire the justices all of the justices
on the united states supreme court i
really do i came from a country that
um didn't respect the rule of law i grew
up where the
law was anathema to everything that i
believe in and i hope that everything
that you would believe in
the massachusetts constitution begins
with the bill of light
it
embodies what is put into the structural
framework of the federal
that it begins with the words
all people are created
equal
actually that was modified by the good
citizens of massachusetts in 1972 it
used to say all men
are clear it's now all people
and there is something extremely
liberating
when that's your starting point
as opposed to congress shall make no law
and so i don't think it's what's missing
and i think it underlies why
thing matters have developed in a way
which might be a little different and if
i can take just
you know one minute to say what the
difference is the very very first case
that came to the supreme judicial court
of massachusetts in
1782 which was we were the constitutions
adopted in 1780
was a case as a challenge to slavery
people forget that massachusetts had
fabley massachusetts had slavery
and was a challenge by a slave to this
new constitution
who were the justices on the court they
were the sitting justices
appointed by who
the governor who was the governor the
king's representative these were not
revolutionaries
but they did in essence what justice
breyer has talked about they took from
their pocket this new constitution only
it was a rolled
quillpin
and they read
all men are created
and if you look at the notes of chief
justice cushing he then was
they are very simple
your skin has a different hue
your nose is flat
and your lips are wide
i'm not making this up
but
you look like a man to me
end
of slavery in massachusetts 1783.
that is a great document
and i would love you all to read
the united states constitution to carry
it around
in your pocket every day not just the
first the fourth the fifth and the
fourteenth
not just the second and the ninth
but article one article two article
three article four
because you have great documents here
the newer
constitutions like the south african
constitutions have different provisions
which are the ones that they now have
justice flyers alluded to one privacy
privacy
we don't have a specific provision what
does that mean
i don't know
privacy
that's an important one and we have to
wrestle with that yeah
it's funny you know i made the joke
about being a psychologist but and and
justice breyer said well what do you
think
and uh
the thought that occurred me is as a
psychologist i wish the constitution had
more to say about had something to say
about privacy and and such because those
are the issues that face us you have to
persuade us
you have to persuade us
how to whistle with those issues
where
the massachusetts constitution doesn't
talk about a lot of diplomacy and the
united states constitution is yeah
you i i don't think it's it's not
perfect the concept we should give you
the final word justice prior no this is
a bad final because this is just a
footnote i mean
of course i i don't think it's perfect
it isn't there's no such
thing as human
perfection
and uh second reaction is i'd like it to
incorporate all my descents and then it
would be a much better document
but i think my reason of hesitating is
because i would be afraid to open the
door to a lot of amendments
i don't know what would come out of that
bag
and uh it might be the things i like the
best would disappear and the things i
like the least would suddenly appear
dangerous thing it's very hard over to
to amend our constitution and i think
that's a pretty good thing
uh
we'll live with it
and
what do i want to final word i've
already had 19 final words
find a word yeah you said i'd read the
document and try and think about it and
if i would take one message away from it
it is
it puts the responsibility upon you it's
you it tells teach them on the next
generation
tell those next generations and that
means you tell your next generations too
and it goes on
what the country is about what the
constitution is about why it isn't just
an object of worship that people do it
helps hold the country together
it does even if they don't know what's
in it
it does
and knowing what's in it is even better
and if i wanted one word it would be
participation
they did four c's
and you say oh i hate what the
government's and the cynicism that is
kind of flowing is really reason to
press that point of participation
you don't like what's happening
well persuade some others
that's the system they find
it's called the majority wins
not perfectly it doesn't work perfectly
but there we are
nothing does
so that that is uh if it's a message
it's a fourth of july message and this
isn't the fourth of july it's the 17th
of september but it's the same thing
please join me in thanking justice
breyer
thank you that was terrific great hour
thank you